[music]
You have a table for one.   Just
a second.  And he is not alone.  He has an
account at Tochkobank and 24/7
support.
Accounting and bookkeeping for business
free of charge.  Business will continue.Nan.
Who should not be hired?
Me.
boy who
I don't need to take on I am a very bad
worker.  I would never in my life hire me
.
Not married, who does not have,
who is not married.  So
I won’t hire anyone who is native to Barnaul
.
Damn, what does Barnaul have to do with this?
[laughter]
Why Barnaul?  What's Barnaul up to?  Well, this is
exactly the
kind of self-portrait I am.
Yes, to this [ __ ]
he is still an [ __ ].
When you speak publicly, you need to
filter the database.
There is somewhere to retreat, he will run
all over Barnau and so on.  But the
boy who moved here from the
village was also an only son and
had no father.  If he is 30 years old, in
fact, even if he had parents, well, he
has parents, but,
in short, he does not want an employee for you, but a
slave.  That's all he says.  I want
my employee to be in dire
need, in terrible dependence, with a
scalded ass and to suffer.  That's when he's
supposedly a good worker.  Dude, I have
bad news for you.  Yes, perhaps need does
motivate people to work, but it
motivates them to survive and work the minimum
possible, the necessary.  And if you want
to fly to Mars, you need people, people
who are motivated by desire, by aspiration,
and not by need.  And I don’t know what kind of business
this guy has, what he’s talking about, and what
he actually does, but
probably if he works in construction,
he needs these, I don’t know, ditch diggers, a
wife, a
good plan.
I'll take a boy like that.  He already
has a ko, I
still have a question.  Is he going to
hire girls or is he only
interested in boys?
You answer and so on.   We do
n’t just look at the portfolio, we don’t
just look at where the person has worked, but
we also look at their personal qualities.  But these are not
personal qualities.  They are not talking about
personal qualities, they are talking about
life circumstances.
Oh, I found an orphan with no home and no money
from another country.  I took his passport away
and now he works well.  This is what he
says.
Well, man, this is a bad idea.
Or maybe you just can't motivate
people?  Maybe you're not interesting?  Maybe
the work you offer
doesn't inspire or motivate anyone.  You
can only work because you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
.  There is simply nowhere to live at all.
What do you propose?  What kind of work is it?
[snorts] And in this job you can
work not out of necessity, not because
life, circumstances
or someone else forces you to.
What don't they do?  I don't know.
I just came in the last year.  These are values.
That's another
2 [ __ ] minutes.
Personal quality.
This thing is called social icaria.   Do
humans have social yaks?   I
came up with some name.  Social
anchor.
In total, here is a professional
char, it tracks 19 basic
social anchors only.
Here goes this dark [ __ ] science, these
social anchors 19 basic.  Scientists
have proven everything.
And [clears throat]
what 19?  Why 19?  He will list them.
I don't know.
If at least, roughly speaking, four or five
of them are likely to be
invested in a person.  Well, let
's say, oddly enough, one of the
social Icari, he seems
simple, but he is effective.  So,
all other things being equal, a woman
will choose a place of work that is,
roughly speaking, within 20 minutes’ walk from her
apartment.   He
tarred all women with the same brush.
Everything, of course.  [sighs heavily]
Oh, boys, women are 20 minutes,
people are more complicated.  You can't do this to people.
Motivating people is much more complex.  And the
greatest heights and results are achieved by
people not because they have a need and 20
minutes before work, but because they have a
burning desire and a super goal.   People
don't fly to Mars out of necessity.
It is oriented, yes, towards convenience and all things considered
.
And people don't fly to the Moon for convenience.  The three of them,
[ __ ], have been sitting in diapers for a week in 2
square meters.
This is inconvenient.
All other things being equal, the black guy will immediately
say: "Aha, this one lives nearby,
we're already considering it."  Secondly, let's say there is, let
's say, a child's manual on how to
hire a really shitty team of
unmotivated people who will
work and hate their job.
[sighs heavily]
Great [music] plan.  5 and 8 year olds are already
sick, younger ones and so on.  Oh, we are definitely
considering it.   It
just feels like he's
taking away some kind of horses' children.  There will be 5.8
or
but with a husband, yes, married and so on.   What I
read here is, first of all, what really
pisses me off is that he
talks about people as if
they weren’t people, as if, by God, he was
picking out a
draft horse for himself.
Yeah, it's all [ __ ] more complicated.  Everything is
much more complicated with people,
especially with good, creative,
constructive, talented people -
much, much more complicated.
Next.  Well, they live in the same ear.
This means for sure, well, what are they saving up for?   We are
already considering expansion and an apartment
.  And she actually has a really
old car.  But in
fact, if we pay her extra,
in fact,
and if she has a 1969 Mustang
,
well, and there’s also a Mercedes G-Class
[laughter], it’s old,
for minor repairs, and according to the standard method,
repairing this car costs more
than your office.
Consider cutting fuel costs altogether.  That's when she's like this, he's
looking for such poor people, so what kind of
people are they, who does he want to hire,
that fuel costs are
critical.
Here we also need to understand that all
employers, all these
theorists, and I, among others, have
different ideas about people and
employees, because different employees,
different businesses.  It’s one thing,
indeed, I’m in charge of construction, I have
4,000 monolithic workers there.  It’s a different
matter if I run an architectural bureau, I have
100 architects, or I have
programmers.  Or maybe it’s me who
tells everyone all the time, I remember as an
example, I say, imagine,
your business is called Universal Music,
and your employee is Madonna.
What, he'll be Madonna?  They say it's far
from home for me to travel?  Here.  [laughter] And how would he
reason if your employee is, I don’t
know, Richard Gere?  Well, there are
employees like that, right?  And with Tom Cruise, it's as if it were necessary
.  Look, fuel and lubricants.  How much does Tom
Cruise spend on fuel per month?  Something like that
.  And his car is old.
By the way, he'll
look at it here, she'll choose a girl she
can invest in,
who she can work with.
And this is disdain.  Boy,
girl, who the [ __ ] are you?  Boy,
girl?
I would definitely never go to
work for him.  I don't even want anyone to talk to me like that
, damn it.
Which can be taught.  And when will you take it?   It's a
pity I'm not from Barnaul.  There is a chance of
getting into something like this.  Mesh twenty-five-year-old
whistle.
Whistle, damn it, just listen to it.  Are you
[ __ ] nuts?  Whistle, [laughter] [ __ ],
why are you talking about people like that?
[snorts]
And even better, 22 years old, whose main
task is simply that she’s terrified that
she’s not married yet, damn.  Who
has her own apartment.  The parents bought a
good car.  Do you seriously think that
I would like to look at his daughter?
This bunny, even if she
shares your values, will work for you for a long time
and efficiently.
Horror, horror, nightmare.
I'm done, I'm finished.
[laughter]
What kind of people do you hire?  Do
you even have any kind of
personal value?  I'll take this kind, but I won't
take the other kind.  [snorts]
I try to employ people
who don’t need to be forced to work,
who want to work themselves, who
have their own drive, motivation, a
burning desire to do their job well and
become better.  And I don’t think that we should
motivate people with need and
fuel costs.  This is ass.
But I need creative people, I need
programmers, developers, designers,
managers, so in my case this
doesn’t work.  Well, and the most important thing,
[snorts] uh,
we can’t call people either girl,
or boy, or whistle.
I even try not to use the word
employees, in case you haven't
noticed.  I'm talking about people.
Even the word "shots" makes me cringe.
Uh, so
you know, there's a lot hidden in these words
.  Uh, I think the basis of a
three-way relationship is respect.  You
have to respect, uh, the person with the employee.
The employee must respect you.  Uh, if you
start talking to them like boy,
girl, whistler, they definitely won't
respect you.  Yes, probably, of course
, if you
start from the need and from the, uh,
life circumstances of people, rely
on them, exploit these
circumstances, yes, he talks about
this.  He says: "I will find a person
who has a hard fate, a hard life,
and I will exploit it."
[laughter] Well, you'll probably get these
people to complete some production
tasks, but you're definitely not going to get
motivated people who want to, I don't know,
do 100 times more.  Well, yes, well, I don’t
know what kind of business this is.  I don't know.  I do
n't know anything about this person,
sorry.  I don't know what business he is
in.  I might have just
said something nasty about him, and he might be
offended, but I don’t like the way
he speaks and what he says.  These are
definitely the
top five businesses [music] that
always survive.  Save.  This will help
you.
Wastewater disposal, electricity supply,
heat, energy carriers.
They always survive,
no doubt about it.  start whenever
you decide, [music] right?  First and
foremost, it’s food, production,
sales, delivery.  People can do
absolutely nothing like that, by the way.
They can save on absolutely everything,
[music] except food.
Nothing of the kind.  People can
save on food.  And we saw this in
the nineties, when they ate from the garden and
didn’t buy anything, but grew their own
potatoes.  Food is a very bad business
because it is very competitive.  Moreover, the
competitive competition is endless.  You
can compete with a vegetable garden,
with difficulty.  That is, a person can
grow his own food and,
in theory, feed himself.  Moreover, a person
can constantly simplify his eating
habits.  He can stop eating
beef, start eating pork, stop
eating pork, start eating poultry, and so
on.  Give up protein altogether.
So no, no, no.  [laughter] And what’s more
, the more we go down to the more
basic level, the lower the
marginality will be.
No, food is a very good business during a crisis.
The second is repair.  [music] Yes,
everyday.   Are
you out of your minds?  [snorts]
Another very bad business crisis,
because there’s no need to
repair anything.
And he talks about repairs out of necessity, when
my phone broke, I went to
buy a new phone, and I repair the old one.   There
will be such a bloodbath there.  Who will
do it for 20 rubles?  cheaper, will
take the client.
Good business.  This is not when we sink
space and pay for it out of our own
pockets.  Good business.  When we are a
marginal business,
repairs on demand are a super-low-margin
business with super competition.   There is
no money there.
You will earn very little and die.
Oh, construction [music] auto repair shop.
Yes, a crisis is a time to fix things, not a time
to buy new ones.  You know.
And cut, cut, and cut.
[music] Third is transport and
logistics.  While they're
[ __ ] going.   The
first thing to suffer when
the economy declines is transport and logistics.
Because transport and logistics are a
direct function of GDP.  There is even a
method for assessing economic growth based on
demand for freight transport.
One of the objective metrics of the state of the
Russian economy is
freight transport by rail.  They
grow, which means everything is good in the economy;
they fall, which means everything is bad in the economy.
Transport and logistics are directly
correlated with the economic situation in the
country.  Accordingly, if there is a crisis,
what will happen to transport and logistics?
It will fall.
Cargo.
I'm waiting for two more cool ideas.
Money always goes around, [music] right?
The fourth is packaging.  That's it,
damn it.
[laughter] This is the fourth thing that will die in the
crisis.  The only thing it will save is on
packaging.   Are
you kidding me?
Oh.  Adadadada.  Fifth.  The fifth will be
something that needs to be stored, transported, [music]
sold.  We need to pack it somehow.  Yes, and the
fifth.
No, there is reusable packaging,
[laughter]
it’s a string bag instead of a bag.
Oh, the
last thing is agriculture and farming.  Who are
you?
Holy [ __ ], [snorts]
he didn't let me down.
Farming and agriculture.   a
super low-margin
business with large capital investments
and global competition.
Another problem of the agro-farming
business.  You are constantly competing
not even with your neighbor, but with a farmer from
another country.  That's why farmers are
constantly being protected everywhere.
And we have a problem.
We have bad weather.  Don't
tell anyone.
That's four tomato harvests in Brazil.
It's a secret.  Nobody knows.  [laughter]
And in Chile there are five potato harvests.
[snorts]
We compete poorly with agricultural products.
Nothing has been growing here for six months, [laughter]
you know?
And in order for tomatoes to grow, they need to be heated
in greenhouses.  It's expensive there.
[laughter]
Worst business you can be in.
[ __ ], in the north
it's farming, [laughter]
you know, [ __ ].  [snorts]
Oh, I can't.
Oh,
well,
okay.  [snorts]
They take out food, they make money here.  [laughter]
Well, that's all there is to it, basically.  Ah, well, are there
any options for small
businesses to survive the crisis?  What, what should we do
?
Well, that can't be done.  Well, the question is, what
resources do you have, what competencies do you have,
what position are you in?   The
main idea I really
liked was
that if you're not a monopolist, if your
market share in any niche is less than
15%,
you don't care about macroeconomics at all.
Even if the market is reduced by 20%, it is a
nightmare, a catastrophe, a bloodbath.  You
can grow twice as much
simply by taking advantage of other players in the market.
Moreover, a crisis is a wonderful time
for those who are efficient and profitable
compared to their competitors, because when the
market falls, your less profitable,
less efficient competitors will
die out and free up space for you.
Therefore, if, for example, you have a very
high margin and efficiency, a crisis
is a great time for you, because it
will wash out your inefficient
competitors, and you will take their
share, and you can grow greatly due to this
.
As Buffett said, a crisis is a time
when you can see who's been swimming without underwear.
Accordingly, if you are efficient and
profitable, a crisis is the best time
for your business.
If your competitors are inefficient and not
profitable, yes, if they are also
efficient and profitable, well, damn, that's a
problem.  So what kind of business is it, what are
the conditions, what skills do you have in this business,
where are you located?  Well, you can't
give advice so indiscriminately, but this is just
fundamental [ __ ].  All five ideas are
complete crap.
Brands are closing, the video says.
Russian brands are closing one after
another, but no one explains why or
what to do.  Global brands survive
because they're embedded in people's lives.
As soon as the narrative starts:
brands are closing, restaurants
are going bankrupt, everything will immediately go
downhill, you can stop watching.  Well,
this is too unfounded, but this can’t be done.
What brands?  Why?  And what percentage?
Now restaurants are closing;
340 restaurants closed in January.  Is this a
lot or a little?  And how many opened?
How many closed last January?  And it
turns out that 335 closed last year.
Six more than last year.  This
looks like a disaster.
In short, any unfounded statement along the
lines of: brands are closing.
In principle, you can close the video.  Most likely it will
thunder, but we'll see.  subcultures,
sports, music and the like.
Most Russians sell things, but
do not sell the meaning of ideas.
Oh well,
everyone is so stupid.  You are the only smart one.
[snorts] They
don't convey their [music] position or
way of life.  Difficult.
What is this?   That's all everyone does
.  In general, this is all any
brand does.
Moreover,
Gazprom is making up dreams.  That's how it was there, for
example.  What is this in your opinion?  He doesn't
write advertisements.  We sell gas for 5 rubles.
6 kopecks per cubic meter.
[snorts] This is what Gazprom advertising looks like.
She looks different.   It
was 20 years ago, I remember.
The economy, difficult weather during the season, but
there is also [music] objective reality.
which Russian clothing brands
cannot.
And
I didn't understand about the clothes.  [snorts]
Create [music] a clothing brand, but
only create its facade.
What is this?  [laughter]
What is this?  That's all everyone does.
If I'm wrong, please correct me [music]
in the comments, I'll be glad.  What is there
to unwind here?  [laughter]
Like, you know, all Russian brands are
crap.  Well, I'm wrong, please prove me wrong
in the comments.
You say, oh, dad, what is there to unwind?
No, it's crap.
No, you are wrong.  That's it, we've got you unraveled.
Okay, let's go home.  All.
Were there any arguments there?  None.  What is there
to unravel?
No.
All brands around the world always
do just that.
And
yes, perhaps if it's a very small
company, it does it poorly, ineptly,
simply due to a lack of competence, but
any more or less
developed company will
do only this.  Especially, damn, in clothes.
Where else, if not in clothes?
And no, Russian brands are not different in any way.
And then, when he talks about Western
brands that he admires,
which Western brands is he talking about?  About Brazilian ones.
Maybe about Indonesian ones.   What
kind of West is he talking to us about?
Dude, name five German
clothing brands.  What, you can't?
They are not there, in your opinion?
He also takes Top of the Top.  He
says: “Well, there’s Nike, they’re doing everything [ __ ]
awesome.”  And our Russians are all
crap.  Compared [laughter] Nike and
all Russians.   Is that what he
does?  Or he says:
“Look, there’s a good brand in
the West called Louis Vuitton.”
And here everything is some kind of crap,
some kind of brick platinum.
But we have good, strong,
local brands.  They do everything
right, they grow little by little, they learn.
Maybe some of them will become
global.  I think even someone
became one.  I might lie now.
Who do you like because of Russian
locals?   Are
you asking me about a separate brand?   Yes.
as the main fashionista of YouTube.
I am a great expert on clothing brands.
Yes, I do, yes, you can tell by me.
No, I don’t know much about
domestic clothing brands.  Well, I'm smart enough
not to compare this
Zarina with Nike.  Yes, well, I understand something
a little, yes, that here
we are talking about slightly different things.
And we must understand that there is truly
little Russian luxury, because luxury
can only be global.
But the mass market has its own rules of the genre, its own unique
selling proposition, its own values.
And it seems to me that, as far as I understand,
in the mass segment, everything is fine in the
low end, yes, and Russian brands dominate there
.  Maybe they dominate not because of
some message there, but because of the
distribution of the location.  Well, Zara does
n't have a message either, does she
?  One of the most, if not the most
successful global clothing brand, Zara, has a
message like, we make copies
cheaper and more accessible.  Let me remind you
from the start,
what other message does
Zara have?  How is Zara different from our companies
and what does it compete with?
Yes, I don't think so.  She makes good,
affordable, world-class clothing at your
local store.
And this is a wonderful case, in my opinion.  As I
understand it, the Index company, yes, it is one of the
largest companies in the world, one of the
most successful.
But in general, if you go big for fashion, who will be
your branding partner and
... I've said it many times, I'll be amazed by
UAZ as a brand, by KGB,
our best brand, Stolichnaya vodka.  We
have a huge number of very successful
brands.  The most successful KGB today is
100%.
What is this?
KBK.
[laughter]
We do such things there on the
planet.  Well, if you listen to Western
media, we are simply and immediately
aliens, and then we are.  [laughter]
It's a powerful story that
can objectively be exploited.  I think it would be easy to
release some kind of
spy products
and position them as Russian
spy equipment.
sell somewhere in Brazil.
[snorts] Are
there
any GPS trackers?
Listen, is there a correlation between the two?   I
just wanted to ask you.  There is
another brand: Great Russian Hackers.
Well,
well, you're an opera singer.  This is the path.  Well,
by the way,
our information security specialists are working on it quite well now
.  There is positivity there.  They are now
trading quite well all over the world.  That's exactly it.   It's
just that the average person can't see it.  The average person
doesn't understand this.  And we have a pretty good
brand there, quite a global one, good.
Kalashnikov.  Awesome brand, huh?  Why do
n't we monetize it?  We're just doing a very
poor job of monetizing it all.  We don't know how to
make money from this
objectively.  But we have a huge
number of global super brands.  Uh, and
if we go beyond clothing, even though
there is a ushanka hat in the clothing, that we are not
exploiting it,
that we haven’t played enough with these scarves of
ours.  There was some good potential there too
.  Now they
are trying something, but,
in short, we have brands
that have developed organically,
historically, and,
in general, there is something to be proud of.  If
you want me to comment on
a video or maybe your
video, send me comments via Telegram, we'll
definitely comment on everyone somewhere
.
[laughter]
[music]